[Música]
la historia en beta box quien estuvo
aquí en el textura vida en el año 2016
es una historia acerca de la
excepcionalidad una historia acerca del
espíritu de búsqueda y esperanza que
florece el encuentro de esta mujer
entre esta mujer completamente salida de
su época y un país completamente salido
del contexto geopolítico
este virtuoso encuentro genera la
combustión perfecta de una explosión de
cambios significativos en un momento
crucial de la historia la humanidad
en los años 40 los temas pertinentes de
las discusiones más importantes de la
actualidad mundial como la igualdad de
derechos y oportunidades las luchas de
género la migración por decir algunos
son el cuerpo de su historia el
paralelismo del desarrollo de la música
en concordancia con el transcurso de la
vida de doña henrieta genera una
partitura que evoluciona musicalmente
junto a la historia henrieta nació en
1918 momento en el que el ballet ruso de
parís está en álava música de erik satie
por eso es que la abertura está escrita
rememorando la música impresionista de
este compositor francés
[Música]
i
[Aplausos]
[Música]
para poder contar esta historia
musicalmente escogimos un instrumento
que fuera protagónico el clarinete que
es el instrumento que tiene el maestro y
seguir dedicada tiene en su esencia el
mismo espíritu de dieta siendo este un
instrumento desarrollado en la europa
del siglo 19 que gracias a su gran
versatilidad sonora y técnica amén de
haber nacido en la música clásica formal
se aventuró a nuevas escenas cruzó
continentes enteros y se fundió con
nuevos géneros insospechados para sí se
parece a alguien por ello podemos
encontrar el trenet en la música
balcánica en el jazz de nueva orleans en
la música del altiplano en la música
oaxaqueña
[Música]
e
entonces con estos dos elementos la
evolución de la música en paralelo con
el desarrollo de la historia en dieta y
el espíritu del clarinete vamos a
escuchar este tercer hilo de la historia
que es la canción misma
en la voz de la maestra de mico el
laurel escuchó una voz
[Música]
esto
con él
pues sí
misa
qué es
[Música]
i
which is
que se refiere
a un sol brillante
la ciudad palpita que bien vende sol
en mi mente bien
a la vida
de
hecho un nuevo suelo y beloki
[Música]
tú
vivo paras
lo que me
[Aplausos]
única
[Música]
por eso
hoy
[Música]
sí
de la iglesia
todos
y te
escucha una voz detrás de la colina
de nuestra ti pues quizás su sangre que
fluye
[Música]
que seré delante
lo que se ha vivido y la ruta de las
niñas fuerzas para hacer en la sombra de
alguien más no me quiero mirar mando de
un temprano
[Música]
rico
[Aplausos]
bien
estoy
[Música]
a
y
[Música]
d
escuchar
o
[Música]
así es como la música que el mundo
occidental escuchaba en el momento en
que estas escenas sucedían en la vida
real
acompañan cronológicamente el desarrollo
de la historia
por ejemplo el discurso de don pepe en
radio américa latina' se acompaña
perfectamente con un foxtrot
[Música]
la historia en riendo box es la historia
de una gran mujer que género y acompañó
grandes cambios desde esta sociedad en
la que vivimos hoy hitos en la historia
que ubican a una costa rica en un lugar
único
con realidades que nos parecen quizá
gratuitas hoy pero que costaron vida y
milagros de quienes la gestaron quizás
una de las más grandes de ellas es la
abolición del ejército la canción de la
abolición del ejército hasta la manos
del maestro fabián arroyo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ellos entregamos nuestra
sangre
en el pasado
que nunca más las ansias
militares disparen hacia el pueblo
[Música]
i
d
de los retoños de la
vida
el cielo sólo a él
[Música]
nada más jugar es en las manos nos
buscando en hermano el corazón
que están verdes tanto nuestras madres
que prive del derecho y la razón
que evite destruir
[Música]
y
el sueño de bolívar y más y
que buscará el amor de nuestras manos
[Música]
ah
si nunca
el sueño de bolívar
[Música]
que en busca del amor
o no
en el poder
[Aplausos]
[Música]